one of the hallmarks of the american
legal system is that anyone can file a
lawsuit for
any reason at any time
[Music]
and of course one of the major drawbacks
to the american legal system is
anyone can file any lawsuit at any time
for
any reason doesn't mean they're going to
win but they can still
file the lawsuit and over the years many
people have taken advantage of this
principle to file a whole variety of
frivolous lawsuits now
many of these cases are filed by
self-represented parties but you'll also
find far too many lawyers willing to
attach their names and reputations to
these suits
sorry must be getting over something but
baseless lawsuits not only waste the
precious time of an already overloaded
court system
they can also be financially ruinous to
the parties having to defend these
nonsensical claims but these cases also
have the unfortunate side effect of
making us lawyer types
look kind of bad but today let's take a
mirror to our
own profession and let's discuss five of
the dumbest lawsuits
ever filed
sponsored by skillshare so where do we
begin well
when someone tries to sue another for a
substantial sum of money we refer to
that as
suing the pants off of someone but
that can literally be the case and in
2005
roy l pearson jr a lawyer and newly
appointed dc administrative law judge
took that phrase quite literally after
custom cleaners a dc dry cleaning
establishment
briefly misplaced his pants the store
prominently displayed a sign that said
satisfaction guaranteed
and judge pearson demanded satisfaction
by suing the owners for 67
million dollars so here's the backstory
of what has become the poster child for
frivolous pants-related litigation in
2005
judge pearson took a pair of expensive
pants to custom cleaners
the business was owned by jin and soo
chung korean immigrants who came to the
united states in 1992.
now judge pearson intended to wear these
pants on his first week on the bench but
the business owners had inadvertently
sent the pants to the wrong location
but judge pearson refused to accept them
claiming that they were not his pants
despite the owners providing
confirmation
through their business records tags and
the judge's receipt now pearson demanded
payment of
1150 the owners did not respond to this
demand so judge pearson then filed suit
no pun intended in the district of
columbia superior court for
67.3 million dollars in damages 67
000 times more than his original
settlement demand
judge pearson contended that the chungs
had failed to honor the legal warranty
established by the same day service and
satisfaction guaranteed signs
displayed at their store judge pearson
apparently had an incredibly expansive
view of the idea of satisfaction
guaranteed
which he claimed obligated the chungs to
undertake any and all actions without
limitation based on the customer's
determination of whatever would make the
customer
satisfied given this expensive and
incredibly literal interpretation of
satisfaction guaranteed
it sort of raises the question who was
judge pearson's legal mentor
lionel hutz mr hutz do you know you're
not wearing any pants
why well judge pierson contended that
the chung's failure to provide him
proper satisfaction constituted seven
separate violations of washington dc
consumer protection laws and using a
complicated formula judge pearson argued
that the owners and their son ki chung
owed
each 18 thousand dollars per day that
the judge was not satisfied
and they had failed to provide him with
same-day service
as part of his damages pearson also
claimed ninety thousand dollars to rent
a car to drive to another dry cleaner
and three million dollars in emotional
distress because you know
he really loved those pants but judge
pearson is not an unreasonable man
before trial judge pearson generously
lowered this
damage claims to 54 million dollars
when this case went to trial it actually
went to trial in 2007 the dc superior
court rejected
all of judge pearson's claims the court
ruled that judge pearson had failed to
prove that custom cleaners had
misled consumers with a satisfaction
guaranteed sign
in fact the court found that judge
pearson was unable to prove that the
cleaners lost his pants in the first
place
and further the court held that judge
pearson's expansive interpretation of
satisfaction guaranteed
had no support under the law shocker
pearson appealed but lost on appeal as
well and because this is america
although the chunks prevailed
they were financially devastated by the
litigation and they were only able to
afford their attorney's fees
after a generous outpouring of financial
support through third party fundraising
in september 2007 citing a loss of
revenue in emotional distress the chungs
closed and sold their dry-cleaning shop
at the center of the dispute and they
decided to focus their energy on
another dry-cleaning shop that they
owned and as for judge pearson
well he did not get to be judged much
longer as he was not reappointed when
his two-year term expired
over a decade later former judge pearson
was brought before the dc board of
professional responsibility to address
his bizarre behavior
in the pants lawsuit and on june 4th
2020 the board suspended pearson from
practicing law
for 90 days the board characterized
pearson's damage theories as utterly
frivolous and excoriated him for his
refusal to accept reasonable settlement
offers the board concluded that pearson
had violated the ethical rule
prohibiting conduct which quote
seriously interferes with the
administration of justice
which takes us to our next incredibly
frivolous lawsuit because
in today's image-obsessed culture people
will try anything to fight the aging
process
trendy diets experimental remedies
whatever it is that keeps paul rudd from
getting any older
but in 2018 a 69 year old dutchman was
perhaps the first person to turn the
fight against the aging process
into a legal one by asking a judge to
legally reduce his age
by 20 years this did not go well but
meet emil rattlebond a motivational
speaker and self-described positivity
trainer from the netherlands in 2018 the
then 69 year old rattlebond appeared
before a dutch court complaining that he
had been the victim of age
discrimination in employment
and through unfair denial of tinder
dates but instead of filing suit against
specific people or
entities that might have wronged him
ronaldo took the novel approach to
remedy his alleged injury by
asking a dutch court to legally change
his birthday from march 11
1949 to march 11 1969 in order to make
him
20 years younger describing himself as a
quote young god
ronald bond argued that his strict diet
exercise routine and mental discipline
had according to his doctors
given him the body of a 45 year old the
judge was first
laughing and then i told him the serious
matter and then he said
well you have a point perhaps i want to
be younger also. in a move that was sure
not to offend
anyone raglebon likened his struggles to
that of transgender people
saying quote we live in a time when you
can change your name and change your
gender why can't i decide my own age
and in a generous offer ronald bond even
stated he was ready to give up his 1500
euro per month
pension in return for the dutch
government shaving 20 years off of his
official age
not surprisingly the court ultimately
ruled against rattlebond holding that
there was no legal mechanism for
allowing a person to change their date
of birth
and in its ruling the court warned that
allowing ronaldo to change his date of
birth
would create all kinds of legal problems
by effectively erasing 20 years of
events
quote mr roloban is at liberty to feel
20 years younger than his real age and
to act accordingly but
amending his date of birth would cost 20
years of records to banish from the
register of births deaths and marriages
and registered partnerships this would
have a variety of undesirable legal and
societal implications the priority must
be to ensure
that the public registers contain
accurate factual information
the court highlighted that specific
dates and obligations attached to age
such as the right to vote right to marry
drink alcohol and
drive a car and that a ruling in favor
of rattlebond could open up the
possibility of a person
declaring oneself older and try to
obtain those rights which pisses me off
just because i didn't think about that
and i really would have liked to have
done that but if ronald bond feels like
he has been discriminated against the
ruling said
that there were other laws that he could
use to invoke and try to seek relief
that way
because at the end of the day he only
has himself to blame
which is also the case in our next
frivolous lawsuit
our next plaintiff took it one step
further and just sued himself
because many people who represent
themselves pro se are filed by those
currently serving time
in prison and many of those lawsuits try
to address a variety of important issues
like subpar prison conditions or
particularly in case of death row
inmates to seek a re-trial of one's case
other times they're just plain weird and
such was the case of robert lee brock
the man who sued himself
for 5 million for violating his own
civil rights here's the story in 1995
brock was serving a 23-year prison
sentence at the indian creek
correctional center in chesapeake
virginia
for breaking and entering and grand
larceny and like many people who make
bad decisions that they regret forever
he was drunk at the time to alcohol
because of
and solution to all of life's problems
and for that brock believed you may be
entitled to compensation
who me yes you you could get
compensation
wow that sounds great i think i'll do
that because in a seven page handwritten
complaint brock argued that his
christian faith forbids him from
drinking alcohol and he argued that
getting drunk caused him to commit
crimes and violate his own
religious civil rights he pleaded with
the court to grant him relief
from himself quote for violating my
religious beliefs i want to pay myself
five million dollars but ask the state
to pay it on my behalf since
i can't work and am a ward of the state
brock sought three million dollars for
his wife and children quote for their
pain and suffering in college tuition
and 2 million to support him for the
next 23 years in prison
but promised he would pay it back
someday the judge was
not impressed and immediately dismissed
the lawsuit as frivolous
in her order the judge wrote plaintiff
has presented an innovative
approach to civil rights litigation
however his claim and especially the
relief sought are totally ludicrous
but brock who would later file lawsuits
under the alias two souls walker
would continue to be a thorn in the side
of the federal court system filing
appeals to the fourth circuit court of
appeals in 1995 through 1996
alone all of which were rejected but
brock's barrage of baseless lawsuits
included complaints about the price of
coffee
improper placement of a mirror for the
handicapped and suing the prison for one
million dollars for mental cruelty
when prison nurses said no to brock's
request for extra meat with dinner
and vitamins in place of vegetables
brock even sued the victim of the crime
that originally sent him to jail
but in his final lawsuit brock alleged
that he was quote either being poisoned
or experimented on
by the prison because the pancake syrup
he was being served contained
propylene glycol food additive that
does also happen to be contained in some
items like deodorant and antifreeze
but it was the syrup that broke the
campbell's back as the fourth circuit
court of appeals decided that
it had finally had enough the court
ruled the case was frivolous not only
because of the propylene glycol as a
common non-toxic extract
but also brock made no allegation that
prison forced him to eat the allegedly
poisonous syrup citing brock's history
of wasting money in precious court
resources
the court banned him from filing any
more lawsuits without a judge first
certifying
that his claim was not frivolous because
the constitution guarantees life and
liberty but it doesn't guarantee
a good time and that's what takes us to
our next frivolous lawsuit there's an
old saying that you can't believe
everything you see on tv
and it's actually a good rule to live by
and it's especially true when it comes
to advertising because beer commercials
often
present a fantasy of beach parties
beautiful women and occasionally
skateboarding dogs but most people
understand this image to be just that a
fantasy but that's most people because
for one michigan man he believed that
budweiser's advertisements in the late
80s were misleading their audience with
an explicit promise of partying and fun
times
and when there's a will there's a
lawsuit so in 1991 richard overton
representing himself sued anheuser-busch
for ten thousand dollars alleging their
advertisements caused him emotional
distress
mental injury and financial loss and in
support of these allegations overton
cited the company's bud light ads which
he claimed promised beer's ability to
make
quote fantasies come to life fantasies
involving tropical settings
and beautiful men and women engaged in
unrestricted merriment
overton alleged anheuser-busch's ads
violated michigan's laws against
deceptive advertising by presenting this
fantasy as reality
while downplaying the destructive
effects of drinking alcohol
the michigan court of appeals dismissed
overton's claims
the court held that anheuser-busch's ads
portraying unrestricted meriment
were merely quote grandiose suggestions
constituting
puffing which is actually a legal term
and could not be the basis of an
actionable fraud claim
the court further concluded that
anheuser-busch could not be held liable
for allegedly downplaying the dangers of
alcohol by
portraying the consumption of alcoholic
beverages in a positive light and
according to the michigan court the
dangers inherent in alcohol consumption
are well known to the public
as a result anheuser-busch had no
affirmative duty to disclose in its
advertisements
risks that are already well known and
decades later overton still stands by
his lawsuit
in a 2007 interview with the kalamazoo
gazette
he rejected the characterization of his
image as a sex-starved loser who drinks
bud light hoping to find pretty girls
overton himself
doesn't actually drink alcohol and has
three children and a wife
for three decades and according to
overton the spark for his lawsuit was
seeing his young children captivated by
spuds mckenzie
the budweiser dog crack open one of
those bls
i don't have thumbs he said quote i
looked at them and i thought this isn't
right
here are my kids being drawn into part
of a culture of alcohol because
of this advertising that's when i
figured something needed to be done and
fair enough i think a lot of people
would probably agree with that sentiment
in a way society has come to overton
because those kinds
of ads regarding alcohol are no longer
really seen
on tv but the solution to this issue
wasn't going to be found in a deceptive
advertising
lawsuit but unfortunately some people
have learned that if you don't like
something on tv
even if you file a frivolous lawsuit you
can still cause pain to the other side
because you can accuse former president
donald trump of a lot of things
and in fact i have actually outlined a
lot of the things that you can credibly
accuse donald trump of
in a variety of videos but there's one
thing that you cannot credibly accuse
former president trump of and that's
having a sense of humor
because in 2013 donald trump showcases
lack of humor by hiring high-priced
lawyers to sue bill maher
for five million dollars over a joke
back when donald trump was just
a failed game show host he made a name
for himself by questioning the
constitutional legitimacy of president
barack obama the first african-american
elected to the presidency and
back in 2011 trump demanded that barack
obama release his long-form birth
certificate to prove that he was born in
the united states
after obama released his birth
certificate trump continued to fan the
flames of racist conspiracy theories and
in the run-up to the 2012 election
donald trump said that he would donate 5
million
to charity if obama released all
passport records and college transcripts
and enter bill maher host of the
eponymous hbo talk show and in
mocking trump's demands that obama
proved his eligibility to be president
the comedy host demanded that donald
trump provide his own proof of parentage
namely that he was not quote the love
child of a human woman
and an orangutan from the brooklyn zoo
and on january 7th 2013 bill maher
appeared on the tonight show with jay
leno
where he continued to demand that donald
trump prove he was not sired by a great
ape
and he marched into court with his birth
certificate and sued me
because he's a one-y little and in
turning the tables the very next day
trump through his attorney sent mar a
copy of his birth certificate
and demanded that mar pay him five
million dollars to donate to charity
and yes what i'm going to show you is a
real letter sent and signed
by a lawyer i write on donald trump's
behalf to accept your offer made during
the jay leno show on january 7
2013 that mr trump proved he is not the
quote spawn of his mother having sex
with an orangutan
attached here too is a copy of mr
trump's birth certificate
demonstrating that he is the son of fred
trump
not an orangutan and i want to add that
not only is this a real letter
sent and signed by a lawyer this demand
was not
from trump's fixer michael cohen this
was sent by cooley llp one of the top
international law firms in the world
best known for representing
multinational corporations
the following week the coulee attorney
sent a follow-up demand letter stating
quote mr trump has accepted your offer
for 5 million provided the necessary
documentation and demanded payment
you have not honored your obligation if
you think those letters are strange
wait till you see the complaint they
actually filed in court
because on february 4th 2013 donald
trump formally sued bill maher in
california for breach of contract
demanding immediate direct payment of 5
million to trump so that he might donate
that to the charities of his choosing
the complaint reads like
donald trump wrote it himself or at
least dictated most of it and after
quoting from mars interview with jay
leno trump argued that maher had made a
sincere offer to pay trump
five million dollars if trump could
prove that he was not the son of an
orangutan and the complaint alleges that
a contract was formed when trump
performed by producing his birth
certificate
marr failed to pay the promised sums and
thus mar was in breach of contract for
five million dollars though apparently
they thought
better of it because eight weeks later
donald trump withdrew the lawsuit we
should not be having frivolous lawsuits
like this
the legal system in this country is not
a joke it's not a toy for rich idiots to
play with
it's it's not a collection agency for
billionaires and
while his fixer michael cohen claimed
that trump would soon be filing an
amended complaint
such a complaint was never filed cohen
never gave any reasons for the
withdrawal or why a subsequent lawsuit
was never filed
though some legal scholars do point out
that this lawsuit was
complete and utter nonsense and trump
wouldn't actually be able to recover
anything
also other scholars point out that
california's anti-slap law which
punishes those who file frivolous
lawsuits that seek to chill speech
would have entitled bill maher to
recover all of his attorney's fees from
trump when marr inevitably prevailed and
if there's one thing that we know about
donald trump is that he hates paying for
attorneys
of course the bottom line is that all of
these lawyers who filed these lawsuits
should probably be disbarred and find
new jobs because they filed such
frivolous lawsuits they'd really benefit
from mary andrews skillshare class
drawing as self-discovery five ways to
start because
they'd probably be better artists than
actual lawyers or they could take andy
pizza's class find your style 5
exercises to unlock your creative
identity because
their identity should not be bound up in
actually being a lawyer
or let's be honest they're going to do
what everyone does and start a podcast
probably after watching john logan
marzino's class how to make a podcast
plan record
and launch with success because you can
find almost any class in the world on
skillshare skillshare has classes on
almost everything from video to business
to design
skillshare as you know is one of the
world's largest online learning
communities with tens of thousands of
classes on everything
and it's the best place to get a start
on the internet or if you're one of
these lawyers
a new start on the internet if you'd
like to try out skillshare the first
1000 legal eagles to use my link in the
description will get a free trial of
skillshare premium and after the trial
and skillshare is still way more
affordable than most online learning
platforms with
plans starting at less than 10 dollars
per month plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so just
click on the link in the description to
get a free trial
of skillshare so do you agree with my
analysis are there other frivolous
lawsuits
that i didn't cover that i should leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my other videos on
the craziest lawsuits in the world legal
issues in the news you name it it's over
here so click on this playlist
or i'll see you in court